[Música]
o que é que estás a fazer do que ver o
que é que estás a fazer
ae
o lado pessoal aqui quem fala é dar que
são muito bem-vindos camargo e umas
pessoal apresento vos com o novo morador
aqui da casa
este é o uso que o que para comportar
sem brilho eu adoro amor de morro
para isso foi karubi gostam é fofo só
como é que conseguiu se inscrever de
cunhar para um modo de morder seu último
livro the guardian jack para uma melhora
juiz equipa do momento juke para essa
intensidade minha vida esta última
semana
ganhar ganhar como eu estava dizendo só
esta é uma das surpresas que eu tenho
pra vocês é o nosso novo amigo aqui na
casa que só sabe morder lhe destruir
meias entre pantufas olha aí o distrito
hoje acordei chinês também aqui no chão
um look mais em gravatá a sua estréia em
apenas dois meses e meio e é por isso
que eu não saiba ainda vale o que está
aqui fazer quando este que os clientes
têm poucos dias de vida única coisa que
sabem fazer é destruir a vossa casa
brinca que é eu estou sentindo eu passar
mais tempo debaixo da minha cama e como
artista e sorrindo fofinho não merecem
white que neste vídeo pessoal deixem-me
lá então tá confirmado pessoas o que o
nosso novo animal de estimação aqui na
casa
posso fazer um vídeo a 2009
é que eu vou apanhar da pata da patram
isso muito bem com vocês puderam ver só
vez que não quer sempre o cara é toda
hora o que brincar é um caminho que eu
quero festinhas e é por isso que eu
gosto muito num bom eu tenho dois meses
e é da raça ser moído e porque não sabe
só uma raça essa mulher é uma raça
nórdica portanto eu gosto muito frio e
por isso tem muito pelo mec para
proteger contra o frio e isso não deve
ser um dos mais antigos do mundo da pré
história que foi o primeiro a perceber
que os cães que vocês vêem puxar os
trenós e assim são ser moídos são
brincalhões tem muita força saltou muito
correm muito tem tudo aquilo com que não
pode ter é um sentimento claro não forem
bem decat também podem ser reversíveis
mas esse não é o caso vai ser muito bem
educada e ela te dá a patinha já treinei
pela paradinha e dar a patinha com dois
meses é muito ruim porque está a
passar-se e conta que a única coisa a
fazer é não morrer com tanta força e não
destruir as coisas mas isso é
completamente normal o pessoal por como
vocês devem calcular eu tenho 28 estão o
chile ainda steffi deve doer muito o
deve ter muitas dores então eu preciso
estar sempre manter alguma coisa porque
se ele via muitas dores é quase como se
nós fôssemos bebê e quando estamos tão
típica castiga ea gente que era xuxa
coisas sem isso uma gorda morango olhe
para isto eu quero brincadeira eu quero
brincar comigo não gosta nem massagem no
peixinho né eu sei mas
não é muito engraçado e o pedro mas não
não é assim não é não modo o dono não
iam chama suzuki foi o primeiro nome que
ele quis dar foi suzuki porque sus o que
anda muito muito rápida e ele é um cão
para correr muito é porque os cães ficam
gigante ficam com um enorme correm muito
sério tem muita força também e
abreviação de suzuki que é um cão russo
tem um chip mês que mora em portugal se
faça de bom visto que é muito bem-vinda
eu só posso estar em casa portanto faz o
call em casa eu faço xixi em casa eu
acho que tudo em casa porque eu só pode
estar em casa porque não tenha última
vacina e as últimas assim nenhum vai
levar para a semana se não me engano
ainda tem que ter um pneu mas só quando
aparece uma vacina que pode começar a ir
à rua eu posso começar a associá lo
então eu vou filmar isso pra vocês que
fala demonstrar quase como se fosse um
diário de um tipo mostraram sempre que
for fazer a primeira coisa inclusive
este fim de semana de vida que caso um
cãozinho do amigo e portanto vai
conhecer uma amiga vai ser a primeira
vez que um piloto com zinho então vamos
ver como é que eu criar foi muita coisa
e sério e se quiserem só comento embaixo
também se quiserem que o filme quando o
formulário vacina até acho que é uma
coisa importante é mostrar que o santa
cruz temos aí um zoom que está fazendo
outra coisa muito importante da raça
moído pessoal é que elas têm em seu
poder um sorriso tem sempre um sorriso e
portanto em bebês como adultos estou
surpreso que olha essa imagem está
sempre a brincar só por eu não quero nem
tensão aos inscritos num eu quero
atenção só por aí eu te amo te com força
a bola tinha da patinha não tinha muito
bem está a ser bem treinado isso mesmo
se tornou o biscoito a causa em 1858
a subida tem aqui pra cá e biscoito que
duas vezes sinto cheiro luxa vai mesmo
hora do biscoito ol gosta é bom embora a
esposa é cara do botafogo já não é o vôo
longe inclusive final do estudo biscoito
que bom pessoal mas como ficar por aqui
com esse filho esta foi a apresentação
do novo animal de estimação aqui na casa
que é o uso que espero que vocês tenham
gostado de ouvir vocês vão conseguir
acompanhar o crescimento de eu também
vou mostrar tudo relacionado ao uso que
as idas ao médico os parceiros e vou
mostrar encontros com amigos de wes
brincadeiras eu treinar todo o processo
de treino que vai ter pelo menos um
pontinho nos abordar esses aí já o
primeiro é e onde está a ir à casa de
banho em casa vamos ver o que eu vou
fazer com a minha opinião não gostou
[Música]
o campo não é dos goianos ainda é quase
o que eu vou explodir uma meta muito
tempo já não tivesse uma meta vamos
tentar chegar aos 100 mil likes neste
vídeo só assim é que vocês vocês
gostaram do suzuki no canal escrever
mais vídeos com é local portanto deixem
seio nenhum ladrão que rouba discuto e
só fica bem próximo